of course by now everybody has heard the
really really big news it may not be the
best week for the New England Patriots
on Sunday no obviously that's not the
big news the big news is that Donald
Trump has won the presidential campaign
and is now the president-elect of the
United States we still don't know the
results of some states including New
Hampshire and Michigan and a few others
at this point but we know that even
without those Donald Trump has obtained
279 electoral votes 9 more than the
minimum number required to win the
election let's start with a map of the
election as it currently stands more or
less and you will notice that New
Hampshire is still too close to call as
of this hour Michigan too close to call
and Arizona too close to call but it is
mostly academic at this point because it
would not change the results let's take
a look at some of the specifics here as
I talk you through some of this over
here with the live election map number
one Hillary Clinton may well end up
winning the popular vote here currently
ahead as you can see here 47.72 47.5%
most of the people who voted in
yesterday's election at least as of the
tally right right now did not vote for
the winner Donald Trump let's also just
look at a few states here in particular
you see New Hampshire Hillary Clinton
just slightly ahead right now for
electoral votes would not end up
changing the results if we look at
Michigan you will notice Donald Trump is
ahead by 0.3% that would not change the
results when it altum Utley is called
and then in Arizona Donald Trump Donald
Trump actually ahead by 4.4 percent in
Arizona but it has still not been
officially called for Donald Trump now
what I want to take a look at here is if
we look at the change from 2012 this is
a map from the New York Times where blue
arrows signify a move towards the
Democratic candidate and red arrows
signify a move towards the Republican
candidate relative to how these places
voted in the 2012 election and the
thickest concentration of
Aeros meaning a move away from the
Democrat and towards the Republican are
very heavily concentrated in Ohio as
well as in in West Virginia and you see
it throughout the Midwest in Indiana as
well as in Kentucky Tennessee southern
Illinois southern Indiana rather
southern Illinois as well but very
interestingly and this was the area that
was most surprising to many of us
yesterday Minnesota Wisconsin and
Michigan a lot of red arrows their areas
that moved to the left during this
election a lot of them in Utah and that
really doesn't have that much to do with
Hillary Clinton it has more to do with
Donald Trump and how he just did not
work for the Mormon community some blue
arrows also in northern Georgia and a
lot along the eastern seaboard we did
see some sort of activation and movement
enthusiasm for Hillary Clinton there now
the two reddest states that I want to
show you here we will get back to our a
sort of normal map if you look at
Wyoming where 70% of the vote went for
Donald Trump and you look at West
Virginia where 68 point seven percent of
the vote went for Donald Trump replacing
Utah Utah often the reddest state and
because of the the votes split with the
Mormon candidate Evan McMullen we have
Wyoming in West Virginia as the most red
states yesterday two places I will
probably never visit in my life at least
I don't I don't know that I will but but
things can change life can go in
unpredictable directions to other states
I want to touch on briefly and this is
sort of I'm trying to find some silver
lining in yesterday's election Georgia
Donald Trump won Georgia by under six
percent and when we think about the
possibility of new swing states going
forward Georgia is on the list the fact
that Donald Trump in spite of winning
Wisconsin and being on his way to
winning Michigan as well as Pennsylvania
Ohio etc a very red state historically
Donald Trump winning Georgia by under
six points and then Texas we know about
the turn Texas blue movement you know
under about 9.2 percent win there for
Donald Trump it's not the best but maybe
it tells us something about the
potential future in Texas this is really
horrible the first lady will be someone
who worked in the United States
illegally in direct contradiction to her
husband's own policy ideas and threats
on immigration you guys know right that
the insufferable
Trump supporters that we've dealt with
for the last year on corporate media and
everywhere these are going to be
permanent staples of the media apparatus
now that truly deplorable right and I'm
sure there's gonna be a lot of bragging
going on but you know what they deserve
it
this was a decisive election it looks
like Hillary Clinton's gonna edge out
the popular vote but the whole map
changed our predictions for me it's not
decisive Rachel when Trump lost the
popular vote at least as of right now
that to me is not a decisive win it's
not decisive but it to me the the more
interesting part is the gender roles
here what's actually not surprising but
it's just saddening because basically if
you're looking at the females who voted
for Obama that hasn't really shifted it
stayed at around 11 points but then if
you're looking at the males since they
voted for Romney what in 2012 at about 7
points that's almost doubled so all of
the men really backed Trump yeah we're
going to get to some of that exit poll
data and you know I don't want to scare
everybody but the basket of deplorable
z' that could be in Donald Trump's
cabinet we're talking about disgraced
clown clown's potentially like Rudy
Giuliani Newt Gingrich a hypnotherapist
ben Carson could potentially be involved
in the Trump administration in some way
and the really disturbing part and we
talked about this during our livestream
last night thanks by the way to the
1,500 or so people who joined that we
talked with Sam cedar from the majority
report about how he has an 11 year old
daughter now how can he teach his kids
not to be bullies or misogynists or
sexist or make fun of people with
disabilities when the president is doing
those things and when we look at the
example that has been set in terms of
respect and decorum and and politeness
and really dealing with people in an
intelligent and reasonable way by
President Barack Obama whatever you
think of his policies how can anyone now
raise kids in this way when hey the but
the president made fun of disabled
people and the president is a massage
I think that's exactly the way to
teaches those how you describes
explaining him is kind of the antithesis
of Obama and setting it as an example of
how not to role model yourself after
yeah it's it's very very scary stuff and
I'm gonna go into this with an open mind
okay so can Trump fix trade so it's
better for the people like he says he
can do it if he messes up will report on
it if he does great I'll say hey you
know what things improved can he fix
health insurance he says he'll repeal
the Affordable Care Act which will take
away health insurance from twenty
million people if he figures out a
replacement and lets us know and puts it
in place we'll see how it goes if it
fails it will be on Trump and on the
Republicans which will be controlling
both the House and Senate for at least
the next two years more on that later
some issues there's just no negotiation
on right the Muslim ban Muslim ban
probably is gone Muslim ban would be
absurd Supreme Court Supreme Court's
going to be a disaster and we have to do
everything we can to prevent ludicrous
right-wing justices judges from being
appointed to the Supreme Court what on
earth is going to happen with climate
change under Donald Trump I don't know
the legacy of Obama is instantly in
peril by the results of this election
we're going to talk about that more on
the show people around the world
appalled at this we will also talk later
on the show what is the u.s.
relationship under President Trump to
Russia Vladimir Putin has wasted no time
in commenting on that we will talk about
that a little bit later you know I don't
really remember exactly where I was when
I learned that President Obama had won
election in 2008 and when he was
reelected in 2012 I don't really
remember where I was when George W Bush
was re-elected in 2004 I think I
remember I will remember the details of
where I was when I found out that Donald
Trump was elected president of the
United States because this is a historic
moment in the worst sense of the word
isn't it it is because of his sheer lack
of experience to start with but there's
also about more than 50% of people who
woke up and really feel that they lost
something when they vote because they
voted for Hillary Clinton and that shows
in the popular vote yeah I mean when you
look at the popular vote if you take
Hillary Clinton Gary Johnson and Jill
Stein's vote together then it's it's
certainly you know fifty two point five
percent of the population voted against
Donald Trump and I think that that's
really important